Roy Guttman a trial attorney and author
of a new book lawyers and thieves why
such a harsh title well it's harsh only
if you think it's so it's taken from the
fact that st. Ives is the patron saint
of lawyers and thieves and odd yoking so
it was thought back in the 15th century
but it's about lawyers and thieves and
greed because lawyers are terribly
involved with that perhaps too much so
today you're an attorney do you
associate yourself with that grouping I
associate myself with the lawyers I've
known a lot of these why did you write
this because after 35 years of
practicing law looking back over what
the law had been what it is and what
it's becoming I felt that it was
essential for the public to know what's
going on and what's wrong with the
administration of justice and what needs
to be changed
certainly the lawyers and the judges
weren't changing it and if this book and
an entertaining and witty fashion
carries the message that something's got
to be changed it will have served its
purpose well is this just your idea that
a publisher come to you and say we need
a good anti lawyer book it's not an anti
lawyer book it's a pro legal profession
book it's not an expose or an indictment
it's a revelation and it's an education
and the idea was mine wouldn't wouldn't
such an approach reinforce some of the
negative feelings people already have
about lawyers only if they misread the
book then the negative feelings are in
many instances justified which is not to
say that they're universal but if you
read the book correctly it says that
there are certain excesses the idea of
the emphasis on the bottom-line
commercia ality the in personalization
of the relationship between a lawyer and
the client the perpetuation of mumbo
jumbo and psychobabble so that clients
are helpless pawns in the hands of
sometimes unscrupulous lawyers to give
the public and a stake in knowing what
they've got to do to improve the
administration of justice and more
intelligently shop for whatever they
need by way of legal service before we
go any further let's establish your
credentials I introduced you as a trial
attorney but tell us more well I am a
trial lawyer I'm a graduate of Yale the
Columbia Law School but I have
specialized in my entire
primarily is a civil trial lawyer which
is to say I'm a litigator I don't just
push papers I try cases I examine
witnesses I argue appeals there aren't
too many of us it's a special skill and
it's one that I earn my Spurs in my
experience as any real trial lawyer does
and you work alone though I've affirmed
Grubman Greene and Humphrey offices in
New York but we tried cases all over the
country and I've tried cases in 45
states how many attorneys in the front
nine you've also practiced before the
Supreme Court yes I have and I've argued
what are important constitutional issues
and First Amendment rights and
jurisdictional procedural matters I've
argued two cases before the court but
I've had many in which the issues we
thought were so important certiorari was
sought what is perhaps the listeners
know of the hundred cases heard 5000 are
the pool from which those are selected
to give people an idea of the style of
this book as you said earlier before the
interview it's not a dry tract but the
first line might characterize the rest
of the book it starts out my mother has
sued everyone in our family but me first
of all is that true and what's your
point the that explains how I come to
litigation it comes also to the fact
that people who are involved in lawsuits
are usually not strangers to each other
there's been a great deal of
intra-familial
litigation in my family and I suppose it
demonstrates the bloodline by which I
become naturally something that belongs
in the world of disputes but the next
line after that was something to the
effect is she perhaps you building a
case right right one I mean litigation
has become so commonplace that I can't
say that I'd be exempt from perhaps my
mother's ire but it's another way of
saying the solution to problems whether
they're family or otherwise it's not
always to be found in a courtroom
do you like lawyers I do I like lawyers
I like fighting with lawyers
I like carousing or enjoying their
company may I say without seeming
condescending some of my best friends
were lawyers and some of them were my
adversaries
how would a person properly choose a
good million there's got to be a
chemistry between the client and the
lawyer who might make a good wife or a
good husband for any one person might be
a very unsuitable choice for another
person and I think that you should go
about it using recommendations from
people that you know and applying the
same common-sense judgments that you
make and sizing people up asking
questions many people are afraid to ask
lawyers kinds of questions you've asked
me such as where'd you get your
background how much experience have you
had why do you charge whatever you
charge what are the reasons for that who
will be serving me will it be just you
or how many little flunkies and toadies
and substitutes and replacements will
there be know what you're getting but in
your book you talk about some rather
strong techniques such as never choosing
a lawyer that you like personally or get
along with you're a nice person a
lawyer's not your friend you're not
choosing a lawyer to play golf with them
or to have dinner or to take a trip
together you're choosing a lawyer
because he serves a particular function
which is to say that don't look for a
co-religionist just somebody who's
necessarily going to be an agreement
with you look for somebody who can get
the job done doing it reasonably
economically doing it properly and
effectively well correct me if I
misrepresent this but you and your book
talked about how sometimes you abuse
some of your potential clients and those
that remain in the room you take on no
what I do is subject people to what I
might for better definition call a
stress interview because one of the
things I as a lawyer want to find out
when someone is contemplating a
litigation which is a war do they have
the toughness do they have the
resilience do they have the capacity to
withstand what I know the other side
will do to them I make a judgement and
decide how thick the coating has to be
to protect them against slings and
arrows well give us an idea suppose I'm
a potential client and I've got a half a
million dollar contract dispute and I
want you to be my lawyer
right what are you gonna ask I'm gonna
find out are you at war with your wife
or your children upset with you do you
have a driving while intoxicated
litigation pending against you are you
seeing a psychiatrist are you suffering
from some particular medical problem are
there any other stresses that are going
to hit
with your being able to be a client will
the fact of litigation become the
overriding concern of your life so that
it'll become the center of your universe
and interfere with your life and my
ability as your lawyer to properly serve
you and if I answer yes to all of those
things but still want you will you take
the case only if I think that I can
properly serve you if you with your eyes
open after being fully informed and I
believe in that there's nothing about
your case that inhibits me from properly
representing you yes under appropriate
financial arrangements I will represent
you what kind of deal do you what is the
proper financial it varies from person
to person I don't believe that lawyers
should be partners with their clients if
a client can compensate you on a non
contingent basis that reinforces the
ability of a lawyer to be detached
neutral and not a partner or partisan in
deciding whether a case should be
settled or litigated it prevents there
being a conflict between the lawyer and
the client whether the lawyer out of
expediency is telling a client to settle
if he's got a contingent interest or not
it depends in part upon the magnitude of
the responsibility you're asking the
capacity of the client hey the
difficulties that will be encountered
and a variety of other things that vary
from case to case he charged by the hour
ordinarily that's an ingredient of the
fee but I'm not a taxi driver and I
don't work strictly on a meter one of
the things that I charge for is the
benefit conferred and if I were let us
say in X thousand dollars worth of time
build-out at my customary billing rate
which is four hundred dollars an hour
we're able to accomplish something for
you that were worth millions and
millions of dollars I wouldn't expect
the six thousand dollar fee would be
adequate recompense based upon the
benefit conferred by the specific things
that the lawyer is done you really
believe you're worth four hundred
dollars an hour I have no need out of it
judge by what other lawyers charge and
what it costs to run the firm of every
dollar that my firm charges for my time
62 to 65 cents is overhead where does
the 400 hour figure fit in the hierarchy
a 400 dollar fee per hour in New York
City on Park Avenue
is a on the lower side of average for
people with my background and experience
it varies there are people with less
experience who have smaller firms who
aren't able to do what I do and who are
not entrusted with responsibilities as
great as I handle who will charge less
and there are other people who charge
substantially more you have to be a
straight-a law student and Law Review to
be a good lawyer it doesn't hurt my wife
was a partner of mine was all of those
things I was a high ranking student but
I didn't make the Law Review to my great
regret but being simply a scholar is not
all that a trial lawyer does a trial
lawyer is a warrior and while you may be
good in the library that may leave
something to be desired on the
battlefield
so it's a combination of a lot of things
in which scholarship surely doesn't hurt
but it's not the be-all and end-all of
success in a court I've heard it said
some lawyers have claimed that they
don't need to know the law they need to
know the job correct that was boss tweed
who said that mm-hmm
that's one of the things that lawyers
and thieves is directed against
unfortunately I have found traveling
around the country that there's too much
old boy ISM cronyism and hometown team
that goes on particularly in the state
courts the district leader or the
political party that got somebody
elected to the bench is often just
outside or even in the robing room where
they don't belong they have ex parte
communications
I think that's terribly wrong it's
almost never found in the federal
judiciary where the judges are there for
life have you ever had to hire a lawyer
to represent you oh yes as a matter of
fact I have a case presently pending in
which I'm suing Jim and Tammy Baker and
I started with Melvin belli and now the
lawyers associated with him for bringing
a preposterous case against me in which
they claim that I was negligent when I
was the general counsel for the PTL in
allowing Jim Baker to resign obviously
how could a lawyer be negligent in
allowing a self-confessed rapist or
adulterer a tax fraud and criminal to
resign from a Christian pulpit hey I
didn't tell him to do it and be if I had
it wouldn't be negligent they brought
that case against me strictly for
publicity
and as a fundraising device for Jim
Baker I warned them that if the case
were dismissed or lost I'd seek rule 11
sanctions
I don't mind say Hill 11 meaning that's
the rule in the federal courts which
empowers judges where they think that
the case was frivolous and without merit
to impose sanctions including lawyers
fees against the losing side which is a
rare thing in the American law I don't
mind saying that the judge down there
who denied us rule 11 sanctions
initially was perhaps influenced by the
local coloration of his coal frere those
lawyers were known to him he to them and
he denied it we're taking that to the
Fourth Circuit not just to replenish my
pocketbook but because cases like that
preposterous case should never have been
brought and the price for bringing it is
to at least recompense the person who
succeeded in the case for the loss
sustained in the legal fees which in my
case was very considerable how did you
choose that lawyer in that case I my
malpractice insurance carrier has the
right to designate counsel they offered
me a number of choices I wouldn't accept
them and ultimately I came to choose Bob
Michele a lawyer whom I know of as a
first-rate lawyer and I guess I forced
from among their choices that lawyer the
why he thought was best for me how's
business my business my law practice I
get my hire as I go nobody has a trial
lawyer regularly on staff our firm
doesn't represent banks insurance
companies smokestack companies or other
traditional be paying clients our
business that you want to call it that I
call it a profession is transactional
and you never know who your next client
is or who's on the end of the next phone
call how's business I mean things are
you I guess you're basically saying it's
coming over the transom and you're not
out always has it always has come over
the transom
and on recommendations Jerry Spencer one
of the lawyers in this book was now
defending Imelda Marcos was a very very
hard bitten adversary of mine Jerry
Spence sends cases to me that he can't
handle clients like other people whom I
have represented in the past will send
other clients and even people who've
been
my adversaries will send clients a
lawyer has to continually swim like any
big fish if you stop in the water you'll
suffocate they say that about sharks
they say it about any bill fish so while
it may be true of sharks it's also true
of Marlin and other great behemoths of
the other deeps who aren't necessarily
predatory so I guess I was using the
word play
I mean lawyers are frequently associated
which are indeed and then there's a
chapter in there called feeding the
Sharks shark being the Finley kumble
people which is the thing I greatly
deplore and illustrate as an archetypal
illustration of what's wrong with
allowing the marketplace mentality to
replace professional standards well
perhaps as a lead-in to that theme why
don't you expand a little bit more on
your observation that you believe it's a
profession but you referred to it as a
business as well no I didn't it was you
who asked me if it was the business and
I guardedly said it's not okay all right
I resent the idea that people think any
occupation is a quote profession I hear
somebody say I'm a professional dog
walker now while that may be a useful
occupation and people can do it well a
profession requires a university
education a postgraduate degree an
examination regulated by the state the
issuance of a license which includes an
examination of your moral fitness and
self-policing by the organized members
of the profession
that's a profession but there are trends
toward business like absolutely and my
book records I was present at a
revolution in American law
Stephen Kumble changed American law like
no other lawyer before him or I hope
since and up until the advent of Finley
Campbell a 15 man law firm in New York
was big today we've got six and seven
hundred man firms offices coast-to-coast
and around the world but the part that I
am shocked by is that the establishment
old-line firms the firm's like what does
that
well not CAD well they've gotten larger
but I'm thinking of John W Dave
is firm they had first turned up their
noses at at kumble but now I see that
that firm Davis Polk is thinking of
becoming a thousand man law firm Skadden
Arps which I knew when it was 20 lawyers
has likewise thinking of a thousand
lawyers now you cannot have a law firm
where you don't know who your partners
are and what they're doing in Findlay
Kumble they were partners who did things
that sent them to jail well you better
tell that story because a lot of people
don't know that start about a partner
going to jail no Finley Gumbel well
Finley Campbell was formed by largely by
a man named Stephen Campbell who'd been
at Yale with me he invited me to come
and join become head of the litigation
department I was the 12th lawyer humble
built that firm and he used marketing
techniques and the Madison Avenue idea
and he lured people away the way George
Steinbrenner hires ballplayers and he
thought that what was important was
simply bigness and glitz and glamour
he had senator lakhs all senator long
senator Tydings governor carey and mayor
Wagner in a wing of dead cadavers of
political careers that he used to
impress people that there was muscle in
the firm and he built something that was
so big my wife and I left the firm
because we saw what was intrinsically
wrong the firm continued to grow at its
height it was the fourth largest law
firm in America with seven hundred
lawyers it went bankrupt about two years
ago
owing banks around 80 million dollars
which had been financed on accounts
receivable which may not have existed
and it had about 200 million dollars in
malpractice claims pending against it
there were over 225 lawyers around the
country who were partners in that firm
who may face personal bankruptcy who did
the work it wasn't done by people like
humble they presided over their lordly
manners and they had little Chinese
armies of Nats and young lawyers who did
the work and the buildings as Campbell
said he didn't practice law he
administered well has the collapse of
that firm which made a lot of news
throughout the profession and even made
his way into the general press affected
in your judgment the trend of the
profession toward marketing and more
business suits
take a look at the the industries that
have been spawned as a result of the law
as a business there's a whole press The
American Lawyer and various versions of
the American Lawyer that look into each
lawyers pocketbook where were the
clients moving to and from where are the
tramping of lawyers out of firm a to
firm B etc it's almost like reading the
advertising column of the New York Times
that's not healthy for a professional I
think we add about 40,000 new lawyers a
year to many how many how do you know
it's too many well by the fact that
you've got a population of over 600,000
lawyers that have to be supported and
they do that by foraging and the
foraging is by way of stirring up
litigation yesterday I read in the New
York Times a man named Harvey Meyerson
identified as the president of the
professional liability lawyers of
America was advocating turning trial
lawyers into bounty hunters against the
savings and loan entrepreneurs a five
hundred billion dollar fat carcass that
Harvey and his cohorts would like not
for the public good or the commonweal
but to get a heavy slice of that to is
not good for the profession or the
country suppose a young person comes to
you and says I want to go to law school
right what do you say to them I said to
my children don't there are too many
lawyers the world doesn't need another
unless you've got some special gift
talent or some commitment of some kind
that you want to accomplish through the
law be advised to be a success in
American law is as demanding a
discipline as being a ballerina after 35
years I still spend 3,000 billable hours
a year working and a lot of time that
doesn't get billed that's a servitude
and I do it because I'm hooked on it
because I like it because I'm good at it
but I think that there are other things
that people can do other than simply to
become another lawyer
you're a high profile high income urban
lawyer there's a lot of stories in the
book about people a little different
exelon right are their lives
remarque markedly different from your
own in terms of the practice of law
there's
big difference between practicing law on
Park Avenue and practicing in a
storefront in New York just as there's a
difference practicing in a small town
but as I've traveled across the country
and I practiced in small towns and in
rural communities I can't pretend to be
Joe Doakes but wherever you go for what
whoever the lawyer is and whatever the
case is it's always a versus B there's
always a central identity similarity in
the adversarial contest it's only the
visible external elements that sometimes
appear to be different but it's pretty
much the same you know how to pick
insurers oh I think I do how does one do
that one tries to neutralize one tries
to find a jury you can't find somebody
or six people or twelve people who you
know are going to immediately embrace
your client it's wrong to choose people
and expect that they'll vote they're
prejudiced but I think I can recognize
people who approach cases with a fixed
bias I don't mean that they come down to
the courthouse necessarily to punish
anybody but I know from life and living
and experience in trying cases and
picking jurors that people can't escape
the prejudices and the attitudes that
life has instilled into them and so what
I try to do is to get a cross-section in
a mix that makes me feel well that's the
jury collectively that has an open mind
and if I have an open mind that's all I
ask of God the rest is up to me how is
it that you represented both Jerry
Falwell and Larry Flynt I never
represented Larry Flynt I represented
Bob Guccione and the question is a good
one because people say how could one
person expound ideas which are by
themselves so antagonistic Guccione and
and Falwell and the answer is because in
each instance when I represented them I
was expressing their ideas as a lawyer
I'm simply the advocate for whatever
cause or principle I'm engaged to
represent and so long as it doesn't
interfere with some conviction of my own
that prevents me from representing them
I was able to do so Guccione asked me at
one table sure a penthouse
Bob Guccione said obviously I think Paul
wells my nemesis so you're gonna have to
make a choice it's either me or him
he doesn't pay you anything like what I
do so I assume you'll drop him I didn't
I chose for well you know and one of
those cases came before the Supreme
Court in both I came before the Supreme
Court once on Guccione z' behalf and
once on behalf of Reverend Falwell but
in each instance I was there for a
principle I had different clients
principle in both instances was the
First Amendment in one case on behalf of
Reverend Falwell I was talking about the
excesses of the press and of the right
for even public figures to have their
private lives protected against willful
intentional wrong there's a code of
ethics in the profession is it effective
not as effective as it should be what
changes would you make in it I would say
that the personnel ought to be increased
we should beef up the vigilant oversight
committees or grievance committees and
maybe perhaps instead of letting lawyers
do it themselves
we might invite some laypeople to
participate in these committees and we
ought to give a little more attention to
grievances of people who make complaints
against lawyers or not all crackpots
should lawyers advertise no I think
that's deplorable I hate seeing Jacobean
Meyers
I hate these ads are winning accident
cases is no accident I mean that's just
making us no better than Procter and
Gamble or so the argument though is that
it's made legal services more available
to the lesser income people are people
who have legitimate complaints that
would feel that they wouldn't have
recourse to counsel I'm not so sure that
the quality of the representation is any
better probably maybe worse because it's
done on a volume conveyor belt basis I
don't think you get the kind of
personalized service that you got when
you didn't come to somebody through an
advertising campaign in a way lawyers
have always advertised in one sense they
call attention to themselves but by
doing it in that garish fashion of
putting themselves on Billboard's and
with with flyers under your windshield
wiper
I think it's demeaning to the dignity of
the profession what about ambulance
chasers is that a fair term for some
it's a generic term it describes certain
kinds of people who literally go out and
chase ambulances for accident victims
but that kind of practices my book
reflects is not simply restricted to p.i
cases it includes people who are
squabbling over corporate giants and
merger opportunities much in the same
way that naked ambulance chasers do what
is the role of the ABA and the
profession I wish it were more than a
chowder in marching Society and an
excuse to take a vacation in some exotic
place it does useful things it organizes
the bar as the organized bar into
specialty groups with committees they
propose rules they are a link between
the public and the legislature I really
couldn't think of the profession
existing successfully as a unified
profession without the ABA should a
courtroom be televised yes I was in one
of the first fully televised cases in
Ohio among other things it's an
education and an enlightenment to the
public but one of the other things that
public exposure creates is that you can
do things that are democratic in a
fishbowl a lot better than you can in a
dark closet that's why the fullest
amount of exposure is more likely to
produce the truth and covenants of
secrecy gag orders and other things that
can lead to abuses when was that case
1979 or 80
it was Gucci oneis case against Larry
Flynt in Ohio where I got Guccione a 40
million dollar verdict do you think
television had any effect on the outcome
I don't think it altered the outcome I
think it kept certain people in that
case more honest than they otherwise
might have been if they'd had their
druthers did it affect your own
presentation or that of anybody else no
I don't think so huh you don't play to
the television cameras and it was done
very effectively and unobtrusively do
you think that there ought to be
television coverage of federal courts
well I don't draw a distinction between
a case in courtroom a in courtroom B and
i think that television has shown itself
sufficiently responsible i can't say the
same for the
print media what they did with that
Steinberg case in New York was literally
to turn it into a circus but television
in the courtroom I think is Sagittarii
what about televised Supreme Court oral
arguments what that's really without
drama it's only dramatic two lawyers who
understand the highly technical and
rarefied ideas that are being expressed
there are no witnesses it's simply
judges and lawyers talking about cases I
can't think of anything more likely to
put people to sleep unless they are
themselves lawyers or the Advocate is
particularly articulate and the subject
matter lively there are popular culture
television shows about lawyers I'm
thinking of LA law and a new one on that
the name escapes me at the moment and
there's the People's Court how do they
do in terms of conveying I think they're
as close to the law as as the comic
strips are to Leonardo da Vinci it's not
reality it's exaggerated it's
entertainment what's the greatest
Distortion judge Wapner the big popular
wisdom that he delivers in 30 seconds or
whatever it is it's not the way justices
arrived at which is a more deliberative
process and to tell you the truth I've
never seen la Law I'm surprised at that
why not hey I'm busy practicing law and
when I want to watch something on
television it's not to look at a
fictionalized exaggeration or distortion
of what I do there's enough turmoil in
my life I'd rather listen to Beethoven
again this is the book it's called
lawyers and thieves as a chapter in here
called stage-managing what's that mean
it's my term to describe how a lawyer
ought to properly marshal the evidence
and organizes witnesses so that they
will not put people to sleep and so that
it can be presented in a way remember
it's a somewhat disjointed non
chronological and perhaps even often
incoherent way in which witnesses are
presented and so it's a way of making a
design in the presentation of your proof
the marshaling of the order in which
witnesses will testify and trying to
instruct people how they can manage to
negotiate the maze of legal
technicalities with which they have to
contain
in how they express themselves on a
witness stand how to deal with the
hearsay rule how to deal with objections
with relevance because we don't talk to
each other the way lawyers talk it's
English but it's not a conversation it's
an interrogation what are you working on
now I'm working on a legal malpractice
case against a very prominent firm that
costs its clients seventeen million
dollars unnecessarily and where they may
have been working for the other side
unconsciously perhaps while representing
their client and I'm working on a major
libel case which will be launched
probably next week how many hours a day
do you work I don't build for the time
while I'm sleeping but my work is almost
my life is my work and my work is my
life it's seven days a week it's seven
days a week and there are no differences
of what hour of the day a crisis arises
it isn't only obstetricians who have
babies whenever they come trial lawyer
must be the responsibilities whenever it
happens if not a lawyer what would you
have been I started life as a young
actor and in broadcasting by the time I
was seven until I was 18 but I thought
that life was not as socially useful as
a lawyer and it was also too precarious
and now you're an author is this your
first book it's my first book